all right today we're going to be
talking about the future of Hazel my gay
mantion so I like to make these videos
around once a year or so just to kind of
touch Bass with you guys this feels like
a corporate meeting feels like a
one-on-one like when I'm evaluating
Peter's performance speaking of which
it's almost time for his performance
review I think it's a good idea to
periodically ask yourself what are you
doing like what are your current goals
what are you working towards what is
actively happening right now but then
also what are the plans for the future
and so bam here we have an entire Miller
note board that I've made that is
designed to answer those questions as
well as provide a little bit more
information as to our development
processes for hazel so we're going to
get right down to business in this video
and we're going to talk about first of
all what we're currently working on as a
team which I've kind of set up these
four boards for but then also what we're
going to be working on soon because
there's a bunch bunch of exciting stuff
here actually I've thought of one
exciting thing that I forgot to even
mention here but there's lots of
exciting stuff happening okay so first
of all let me introduce you to this
Millan note board because I had a blast
setting this up and by the way this
video is sponsored by milanote so we're
going to talk about them later in the
video but I'm really glad that I finally
had the opportunity to create something
like this because I think this is going
to answer so many questions and keep you
guys so much more informed with what
we're doing so first of all how do you
get to this Hazel engine.com roadmap is
the link I'll have it over here if you
just open that page it will redirect you
to this milanote page that I've made and
I believe you guys can actually leave
comments as well if you're curious about
certain things so first of all control
shift d uh flips between light and dark
theme I kind of like both to be honest
uh you can see I I drew this beautiful
uh kind of background for the Hazel logo
since it would stay light anyway we're
getting a little distracted so these two
boards here are just kind of information
boards if you double click on them you
can go into them and so here we have the
team for example I showed this actually
in a recent video which I'll have linked
over there if you want to take a look
there'll be like a chapter there called
team where I actually talk about the
team in a bit more depth but this is the
currently active Hazel core team uh if
we go back there's also this kind of
Branch strategy that we have so this is
a great example of something that I feel
like I have to mention every single time
that I talk about hazel in a devlog and
I'm like the dev Branch oh by the way
the dev branch is the branch that we I
don't need to do that anymore you guys
can just look at this um and in fact I
think I can even export this uh you know
as an image or something thing and have
it maybe on the Hazel website so it
doesn't even have to be in millano but
anyway feel free to have a read of that
there's also this section here with what
we're currently working on so if we take
a look at this new C scripting engine
we've got the owner of each feature fix
that real quick and then Peter's gone
through this and just filled in some
information about what Hazel's new C
scripting engine is and one thing that I
really like about the way that Peter
decided to do this is he kind of wrote
this as a story which I didn't ask him
to do that but he did that and I think
that's great because I feel like that's
just really cool to have a little bit of
history and story as to how this feature
came about and potentially how it used
to work in the past and why we've made
some of the Tactical decisions that
we've made this is almost like a little
bit of a Blog and I feel like you could
you could definitely convert Pages here
into a Blog but I just think it's really
nice to have it visually laid out like
this okay so this is the section that
we're going to focus on today the what
we're going to be working on in Brackets
soon because we have more plans and in
fact this isn't everything that we've
planned we've got more more than just
this planned but these were the things
that were on my mind for the not too
distant future so these are things that
I have already started thinking about
and even in some cases have partially
implemented so let's kind of go through
all of these before we do jump into this
section though I have to thank milanote
for making this amazing visual project
organization tool and also for
sponsoring this video so milanote is a
tool for organizing creative projects
and I think just by looking at it you
can probably see that it strong suit is
the fact that you can organize it
however you like to me it feels like the
closest thing to grabbing like a piece
of paper and then just writing stuff
down drawing arrows drawing little
sketches like laying out this kind of
information and organizing it in really
whatever way you can imagine so over
here you have this kind of toolbar I've
customized this Toolbar to have more of
the features that I actually use but
there's even some additional features
down here and it's really as simple as
just dragging them out and then you know
building whatever whatever you want
these things over here are boards
they're basically like sub Pages you can
drag out one of these and then if we hop
on over here another great feature is
that you can choose a template to start
with so for example when I was making
this Hazel board I started with this
technical architecture template which
you can see I took some inspiration from
like these headings and these lines all
of these arrows and Boards that's kind
of the same layout that I ended up going
with if we go into something with a bit
more information you can see that it's
quite nice for just displaying quite a
lot of information but then visually
spreading it out visually organizing it
in a little bit more of a fluid way but
then also it's great for visual stuff
like this like you know I need to draw
this little diagram you just grab a
bunch of these note blocks you can
connect them with arrows just by right
clicking connect with lines give this
line like an arrowead two arrow heads
whatever and you've got a diagram like
this going really quickly but then you
can also just draw like I can just draw
I had my Wacom tablet like hooked up and
I was just drawing stuff like this and
then also the sharing like you can just
hit share up here and then create a
readon link like with one click and
share it with anyone I'm in an incognito
tab here I'm just opening it up and then
here you go it's it's loaded my my page
which is how I'm easily able to share
this with you guys and then of course I
can invite collaborators so Peter for
example he's the one who made this C
page as I mentioned earlier any I'm
getting a little bit excited with all
these features so let me just tell you
that Millan note is available for free
with no time limit or anything like that
just go to my link in the description
below and try it out for your next
creative project and if you are already
using milanote let me know down in the
comments section below how you've been
finding it huge thank you to milanote
for sponsoring this video okay so let's
start with the GPU particle system so
Hazel at the moment doesn't have any
kind of particle system in past games
that we've made for game jams such as
Forest dichotomy and Saving Captain
Chino those games have all actually had
some form of visual particle system but
the thing is that was all entirely
written by me in C like in the scripting
language just during the game Jam it's
not that hard in fact I even have a
video where I made a particle system in
an hour not in any game engine I'll have
the video linked up there but the
problem is it's not like a real particle
system because in that kind of C
particle system every little particle is
an entity in the scene that comes with
all of that overhead it has to be
managed by like a particle manager
system that I've written as well and
it's obviously lacking any kind of real
authoring features everything about the
particles behavior is basically
controlled through C there's no
dedicated like UI in the editor but
aside from that the performance overhead
means that you can't have like hundreds
of thousands of particles or even
millions of particles being all kind of
simulated and bouncing off the floor or
anything like that so in comes this kind
of proper GPU particle system now I am
going to try and be reasonably brief in
this video because each one of these
features is huge and can definitely be
talked about in their own videos so if
you want me to make dedicated videos for
some of these features let me know in
the comment section below you can see
I've even included videos here of like
work in progress so this was uh me
playing around with particles you can
see I've created what looks like a fire
or something this is in a completely
Standalone Vulcan application as well so
this isn't using Hazel's renderer which
is why we don't have bloom or anything
like that here but we have a bunch of
particle controls we have a graph we
have a color over lifetime as well with
this slider and you can see as well
we've got this depth buffer Collision
where all of these particles that by the
way are being entirely simulated and
drawn on the GPU so there's very very
little CPU input the CPU just tells it
these parameters basically and that's it
all of the emission simulation sorting
physics you know even the kind of draw
commands cuz it's using indirect drawing
that's all entirely based on the GPU
there are still some features missing
but we are planning to hopefully
allocate some time to work to this I
mean I I'll be working on this so so
it's really just about me finding the
time to do this but I would love to get
this in for our first release next year
so that's that then we have a a bit more
of a boring one Hazel editor 2.0 I'm
probably not going to talk too much
about this cuz this is is actually a
little bit boring I think I think it's
boring to talk about but it's I don't
think it's boring to do like I'm
actually really looking forward to doing
this mostly because of the benefits but
the biggest takeaway here is just the
undo redo system uh this will enable us
to have a nice proper undo redo system
which I think is going to be quite
beneficial for productivity uh so yeah
it's just a matter of again finding the
time for that but I do want that planned
for 20241 you can see by the way that
cuz this is also planned for 20241 that
is shaping up to be a big release and
now that we have automation uh you know
working it's really good timing I think
because this is going to be hard to test
not to mention that this is going to let
us have automation for the editor cuz we
don't have that at the moment we've only
got automation for well really full like
Ci automation just for building the
engine but we have an automated test
Runner that runs like Hazel's runtime
and plays like a whole bunch of scenes
which test pretty much every feature so
we've got that but that's like the
runtime that's actually running Hazel
scenes and making sure the engine like
doesn't crash and produces the expected
results that's not testing the tools
which is this huge level editor and
that's obviously very important to test
so I'm looking forward to that okay real
time Global elimination I think this is
uh yeah the hottest feature in town as I
mentioned here uh this definitely
deserves its own video it's I I think
it's a very important feature and I I
have some nice almost spin-off features
as well and a pretty solid strategy I
think at least on paper as to how I want
to implement this this is quite early I
haven't started working on this within
Hazel at all yet uh which is why I've
kind of put this down for maybe the
second half of next year or I don't know
what our release scheduling is going to
be like but I've put that down for maybe
around our second release next year but
yes this is going to be a huge feature
and we're definitely going to be using
this in the first commercial game that
we make with hazel and then finally I've
got path trade Ing and cinematic tools
here uh so this I did actually start
working on last year around the time
that I started the r tracing Series in
fact people who have watched like the
first episode of the ra tracing series
you may have seen a little clip of RA
tracing working inside Hazel that's what
this was so I'm finally kind of making
this information public these three
videos I recorded and shared with the
team internally in June last year so
like a year and a quarter later they're
seeing the public light I want to do a
lot more of this sharing uh with you
guys which is one of the reasons why I
set up this Millan note page just cuz I
think it's really nice to share
everything in a nice you know visual
organized way but if we take a look at
some of these videos so this was yeah
back when we made Forest uh you know I
put this in this entire scene gets
created as an acceleration structure in
Vulcan this is all Vulcan R tracing by
the way so it's all using RTX cores it's
Hardware accelerated and uh yeah this
didn't have uh any kind of accumulation
yet so that's why it's very noisy but
you can see this is and it didn't have
textures yet either but this is the
entire scene for Forest so that was
really cool to see and especially I
think inside the buildings where you can
see that there's some bounce lighting
happening I this may have even been just
one bounce I don't know this was very
early then I hooked up some of Hazel
control so you can see this is the
directional light component that we have
within Hazel working with this in the
path traced mode again without
accumulation but you can still see the
reflection of this light basically the
light bouncing off of this surface and
then hitting these other surfaces
indirectly and then we have uh
accumulation which is I think the last
video I ended up recording back then
last year but this you can see when I
stopped moving the camera I don't know
how well this is probably going to look
terrible you can look at these videos on
the Miller note uh page obviously
because I'm realizing now that not only
is this you know a compressed video I'm
recording this in another YouTube video
and then you're watching it through that
so it's going to be even worse quality
but this is quite nice you know
accumulation when it when it stops and
you can see it's all like within Hazel
this is not a standalone app this is not
an experiment this is me integrating it
directly into Hazel so I still call it
experimentation just because it's not a
fully speced fully designed solid
feature yet but it's definitely a good
proof of concept now the second part of
this though is the Cinematic tools
because I don't want to talk too much
about the first commercial title that
we're going to be working on but it's a
story driven game and to me the way that
I want to present some of this story is
via cutscenes I want to have nicely
animated cinematic cutcenes that tell
certain parts of this story and that
requires cinematic tools I've grouped it
with path tracing for this because I
imagine I'll be working on this feature
at the same time but of course they
don't have to be used together you can
use cinematic tools to have rendering
using rasterization for your cinematics
but I also thought it would be really
cool to have the ability to create path
traced cinematics and then even export
them so that you don't even have to do
this for games but think of it almost
like a mini version of blender and then
once we have you know denoising and
postprocessing hooked up everywhere I
think Hazel will really be able to
produce some really goodlooking imagery
so that's the longer term plan for this
and I also want to use this with light
Maps which I talk about in the realtime
GI as well because that's going to be
part of uh my idea for that feature but
that is uh you know the future plan for
hazel in terms of these four features
that they're all under me at the moment
because I have strong Visions for them
and you'll notice that three out of the
four of them are rendering related and I
am the only rendering engineer on the
team at the moment so it obviously makes
sense for me to work on this but it's
going to be all about finding the time
to you know spend on this so I don't
know I really need to find myself a
video editor so Hazel engine.com roadmap
is this link will be in description
below have a read of all this
information will be updating this as
well I think this is going to act as the
central Hub of transparency and really
the Bridge of sharing information from
the team and what we're doing and what
we're planning on doing and how the team
works and all of that with all of you so
definitely check back on this page often
if you want to see what we're doing if
you want to support Hazel you can go to
patreon.com Theo you'll get access to
the engine instantly and you'll be able
to play with it and check out the
development of some of these features
for yourselves in fact the stuff that we
are working on like this C scripting
engine this is on a branch that is
available to you if you have access to
the Hazel repository so I just want to
be clear that access to Hazel doesn't
mean you get access to just the release
Branch or something like that you get
access to all of the development
branches everything the Hazel team has
access to you have access to so you can
take a look at some of these early in
development features as they're being
developed and finally check out milanote
give it a go next time you have to
organize a creative project thanks for
watching I'll see you guys next time
goodbye